herman cain dies of covet president
trump floats delaying the election
and democrats and republicans can't
reach a deal on propping up the economy
as more americans join the unemployment
rolls i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ven shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
slash ben well it is the saddest day in
the jewish calendar it is tish above
we'll get to that a little bit later on
the program i'll explain exactly why
people like me are not eating or
drinking and so it's not
exactly a giant shock that this is just
another terrible day in the calendar
there's sort of a jewish
quasi-superstition that tisha is just
gonna be a bad day all around apparently
that is exactly right we'll get to that
in just one moment but as you may have
noticed a lot of uncertainty
right now a lot of volatility right now
nobody knows what the next day is going
to bring
right now that might be one reason that
you might want to diversify at least a
little bit
into precious metals i've been telling
you since 2016. it might be worthwhile
to invest at least a little bit
in precious metals and if you're going
to invest in gold you should look at my
friends over at birch gold that was back
when gold was 1300 bucks an ounce
now gold is at a new all-time high why
well gold and silver tend to thrive
on uncertainty well massive unemployment
a resurgence in coba that is crippling
local economies
an election around the corner unrest on
the foreign policy front
a lot of reasons why you might be a
little bit a little bit displeased with
the current stability of your situation
another reason why you might want to
take some of your money and put it in
precious metals so i'll tell you again
if you haven't reached out to birch gold
to diversify part of your iowa
ira or 401k into a precious metals ira
or just purchase some physical gold or
silver from them
take a look at it today ask all your
questions get all of them answered and
then think about investing in precious
metals with my friends over
at birch gold text ben 247 47 47 get a
free information kit on protecting your
savings with gold listen i've got some
diversification and precious metals
because i practice what i preach i trust
a birch gold they've got an a plus
rating with the better business bureau
countless five-star reviews talk to them
have them safe help you safeguard your
investments they're extremely
knowledgeable
and they want to help you preserve your
savings tech spend to 47
47 47 when you open an ira in precious
metals before july 31st you'll be the
first to get a signed copy of my new
book how to destroy america in three
easy steps
for free again text ben 247 47 47
ask all of your questions get them
answered and then think about
diversifying into precious metals with
my friends over at birch gold text ben
47 47. the breaking news as of this hour
is the death
of a former gop presidential candidate
herman cain
i believe i've interviewed mr kane on a
couple of occasions it really is
obviously a sad tragic story he was a
stage four cancer survivor actually he
died at the age of
74 his death was announced thursday on
his website by dan calabresi who edits
his site
and had previously written about his
colleague's diagnosis calabrese said
herman cain our boss our friend like a
father to so many of us has passed away
we all prayed so hard every day we knew
the time would come when the lord would
call him home
but we really liked having him here with
us we held out hope you have a full
recovery
survivors include his wife gloria
etcherson and his two children melanie
and vincent
kane was among the highest profile
public figures according to cnbc
to have died from covet at 19. again
he's a 74 year old survivor
of stage four colon cancer and people
are dunking on kane on twitter
because obviously he attended president
trump's rally in tulsa
less than two weeks before being
diagnosed with kovid 19
he had posted about how he didn't want
to wear a mask and this is a rationale
for many on the left to dunk on herman
cain because obviously
if somebody whose politics you don't
like dies of covid then you get to dunk
on them that's the way this has been
working for quite a while here if
somebody posted skepticism on facebook
or twitter
about the extent of the danger of covet
or if they posted skepticism about masks
then you get to dunk on them if they die
is basically the way that our garbage
world
works now here's the reality there are
plenty of people who are dying of this
who have been wearing masks and been
being careful
and there are plenty of people in the
media who've been quite shall we say
cavalier about the activities
in which people should and should not
engage up to and including mass rallies
so long as they're for the public
purposes that so many of our
elite like so spare me some of the
crocodile tears on behalf of of herman
cain from people
who really are mostly just not happy
with herman cain's politics
not as not even as much as as his
politics on covet mostly
they don't like his politics generally
and it's it's it's ugly stuff
it's certainly ugly stuff and very very
bad news kenyan been hospitalized in
atlanta july 1st two days after being
told the attested positive for coveted
19.
according to a statement posted to
social media accounts at the time he
obviously was in like
chief demographic territory for risk
this has been hitting black men harder
than has been hitting white men it has
been hitting people with pre-existing
conditions extremely hard and it's been
hitting people above the age of 70
extremely hard kane filled all of those
categories
he didn't require a respirator and was
awakened alert when he checked into the
hospital
but it took about a month for all of
this to progress
now there's no evidence that he acquired
this at the trump rally the trump
campaign said that every attendee at the
event had their temperature checked upon
entry
masks and hand sanitizer were handed out
not required to use
the july 2nd statement on keynes
hospitalization said there's no way of
knowing for sure how or when kane
contracted
the coronavirus the trump campaign said
after his diagnosis he had not met with
the president
at the tulsa rally so
obviously sad and and tragic news and
honestly i the kind of dunking on people
after they die of covid is is pretty
it's pretty gross it's pretty gross it's
it's especially gross because
there's been so much focus placed on
mask wearing now as you know i have been
an advocate of mask scoring since the
since the sort of professional wisdom
suggested that mask warning was a good
idea
and there have been a several studies
that have shown that there's been some
sort of
minor benefit on an individual level
from wearing a mask but if everybody
does it then the
then the aggregate sort of effect is
good
that said it's certainly controversial
not just in the united states but abroad
the fact is that the the danish the
dutch government
has already said that they have no plans
to mandate mass
minister for medical care tomorrow of an
arc in the netherlands said that there
was
no evidence actually that they were
effective he said from a medical
perspective there's no proven
effectiveness of mask
so the cabinet has decided there will be
no national obligation for wearing
non-medical masks
the head of the netherlands national
institute for public health again i'm
shop vendissel
added that the organization is aware
some studies show masks can help slow
the spread of the virus but he argued
the evidence is not conclusive
and that masks can actually increase the
likelihood of transferring the disease
if not worn properly
he said we think if you're going to use
masks in a public setting you must give
it you must give good training
for it health officials in denmark are
also finalizing a study to be released
next month on the effectiveness
of face masks to determine what the
requirements should be going forward
danish health official hennik bungard
said all the countries recommending face
masks haven't made their
decisions based on new studies he added
the only effective face covering might
be a visor because the virus can travel
through eyes
and cloth masks might provide a false
sense of security
dr anthony fauci actually yesterday came
out and said that the masks might be
enough maybe we should all start wearing
goggles
so there's just not enough known about
the mask wearing
overall that doesn't mean you shouldn't
wear it right i've been again advocating
for it because
it seems to me if there's an incremental
way to prevent the spread of the disease
then you should absolutely do it even if
the evidence is uh
is mixed on this thing at best with that
said to to dunk on somebody because they
weren't the fan of mass scoring after
that i have coveted
is pretty gross it's pretty gross and
again i assume there are a lot of people
there
we had 1500 deaths of coveted yesterday
in the united states i assume some of
those people wore masks
it turns out this thing is really really
transmissible and it may transfer via
the eyes not just the nose and mouth
so before you start dunking on people
recognize that everyone can be dunked on
honestly i think the dunking on people
for dying of covet is a way for people
to dissociate from the possibility that
they may catch it themselves
if i did all the right things he did all
the wrong things that's why he's dead
and i'm not
the fact is that death comes for all of
us unfortunately and uh and all of the
protective measures that we are taking
none of them is a proof positive
guarantee that everything is going to be
okay when it comes to kova this is
very very transmissible and it remains
dangerous particularly in the upper age
range with pre-existing conditions
as herman cain had well meanwhile as i
mentioned there has been this massive
spike in the number of reported deaths
yesterday the united states reported
at least 144 new coronavirus deaths that
was the biggest one-day increase
in more than two months some of that was
backlogged every time there's a weekend
as the week sort of progresses
basically mondays are really scanty and
then tuesdays they start to increase
usually wednesdays are the high point
and then they start to recede on
thursdays and friday in terms of the
the deaths that are reported a huge
number of those deaths came in texas
texas has been lagging behind florida
and california
in terms of death but texas reported
over 300 deaths
yesterday from kovid 19. again it's not
a great surprise considering we've had
this
enormous increase in the number of
diagnosed cases in the united states and
death
as we know is a lagging indicator herman
cain is a perfect example of this he was
diagnosed with coronavirus a month ago
he didn't die until today apparently but
obviously all this is bad news and it is
placing
the shaky economic recovery on even less
firm
footing dr kavita patel on msnbc was
saying another shelter in place mandate
should be considered which again would
basically destroy the economy the chance
is that
we are going to be able to shut this
thing down and that we're going to be
able to shut it down until a vaccine is
developed i i would say are slim
and none all the other countries that
have supposedly done an incredible job
of this over in europe
are experiencing second waves now like
all of them they're all having to
consider new shutdown orders if they if
they don't wish to see this thing
increasingly transmitted many of these
countries are saying we're not shutting
down even if there's a low level
of consistent outbreak uh the fact is
that the lockdowns have not proved to be
incredibly effective
all the way through there's still a lot
of factors here that have to be
considered
if people are social distancing while
not locked down that was happening since
early may in places like florida the
spike really happened
after memorial day and really after all
these giant rallies in the streets
it's very difficult to attribute exactly
where this stuff is coming from that's
what community spread means
community spread simply means you don't
know where the virus is actually being
transmitted
but here was uh dr kavita patel on msnbc
saying we might have to consider a
shelter in place mandate
would you be recommending um a a shelter
in place in these hot spots at this
point
i think it's it's got to be considered
yes now i say that knowing the serious
gravity
with which the implications of that on
working families etc
but chuck we got here because we're not
taking it seriously we've had no
national strategy as you pointed out
and on top of that we we are never going
to
do any sort of economic recovery if
people just don't feel safe so i do
think it has to be considered
one of the things that bothers me a
little bit about this is that we keep
hearing this phrase we're not taking it
seriously we're not taking it seriously
there are certain things that suggest
you're not taking it seriously
and if you are getting together in close
quarters with people and you're taking
no precautions
then you're probably not taking it
seriously enough however i will point
out that again the media was cheering on
people in the streets
by the millions that's not taking it
seriously either
so i'm just wondering what taking it
seriously constitutes is the only
mark of seriousness that would
completely shut down the entire american
economy because that has some pretty
significant
ramifications as well this is
particularly true of young people
now as i've been saying for literally
months basically since this began to
treat all americans as equally
susceptible to covet
is at the height of anti-scientific
foolishness herman cain was particularly
susceptible to covenant 19 he was 74
years old he was a cancer survivor
plus he was a black man which
unfortunately for reasons that
that we really don't understand yet the
death rates and this is true across
western civilization
there are death gaps between black and
white it's from britain it's true in
canada it's true in the united states
as well yeah so you know when we talk
about
how how exactly we trans people back
into the population one of the things
the media are trying to do is on the one
hand they're trying to say that you're
not taking it seriously unless you want
to shut down schools on the other hand
you can go out and rally in favor of
george floyd
you can't have it all different ways at
once the reality is if you want to treat
the
scientific evidence with the with the
most plausibility
what you recognize is that people who
are older and at more risk
need to stay home they may be in in
shape for a shelter at home mandate
if you're talking about people under the
age of 55 in the united states under 11
000 people under the age of 55 have died
that's still a lot of people it is not a
lot of people under the age of 25.
under the age of 25 you're talking about
i believe still triple digits
so that means people probably should be
going back to school
and not only should they be going back
to school it is actually imperative they
should be going back to school
it turns out that the cdc had robert
redfield he suggests that the number of
of
people young people who are dying of
suicide and overdose
is now actually overwhelming the number
of people who are young dying of covid
there has been another cost that we've
seen particularly in high schools
seeing on sadly far greater suicides now
than we are
deaths from covet we're seeing far
greater
deaths from drug overdose that are
above excess that we had as background
than we are seeing deaths from coven
okay so you know that is something worth
keeping in mind when we were talking
about exactly what to do this is also
true when we were talking about
economic recovery as we'll get to in
just a second i do want to talk about
the the partisan nature of so much of
what's going on right now as i keep
pointing out
there's very little partisanship to how
kovid affects people there is very
little partisan
partisanship to how kovitt is hitting
states what we have seen is there's a
lot of partisanship to the media
coverage
and to political response to covet so to
take a perfect example everybody
yesterday was talking about the number
of deaths in florida
it was nearly surpassed by the number of
deaths in california
california continues to have more than 2
more deaths than florida overall
california continues to see
a radical uptick in new cases there
seems to be no trailing off
in california you're starting to see a
little bit of a trailing off in florida
a little bit of trailing off in texas
you're not seeing anything like that
in the state of california in terms of
of deaths california had 195 deaths
reported yesterday
florida had 216 deaths reported
yesterday but apparently we're not
really allowed to mention that because
california is a blue state susan rice
who is desperate to be
joe biden's vice presidential nominee
yesterday she suggested that
all of this is of course trump's fault
she was on the view a repository of all
stupidity in the united states
and she suggested that if obama had been
running this thing it would have been
wildly different which again the
evidence just does not show this here
she was explaining that the obama
administration gave a pandemic for
dummies
playbook to the trump administration
which as we will see is kind of weird
since they
really did botch the swine flu thing the
difference is that the swine flu is not
nearly as communicable or as deadly
everybody who knew anything about
national security
global health understood that a pandemic
was inevitable i write about it
in my book that we were just talking
about briefly at the outset
uh we prepared the incoming
administration with a pandemic from
dummies playbook and a tabletop exercise
and so many other briefings so the fault
here the the tragic loss of 150 000
americans and
counting is on donald trump and his
gross mishandling of this pandemic okay
there's a lady who wants to be vice
president of the united states but let's
look at the facts on this the fact is
that the
obama administration when it came to
swine flu they did not handle it all
that well it just turned out that swine
flu is not nearly as deadly in the
united states
as as kovid has been i mean the l.a
times reported that after the swine flu
epidemic in 2009 a safety equipment
industry association
and federally sponsored task force both
recommended depleted supplies of n95
respirators
be replenished by the stockpile that
didn't happen the first us case of swine
flu occurred in california it was
identified
april 2009 on april 25th the
world health organization declared h1n1
a public health emergency that was
echoed by obama one day later
the whole declared h1n1 a pandemic june
11th it took obama until october
to declare a national emergency so the
fact is that
you know no one has a great handle on
this and anybody who's pretending they
have a great
like human beings have a need for
control it makes sense we live in a very
chaotic difficult world
human beings have a need to feel in
control but the fact is that when it
comes to cover 19
there just ain't that much control you
do what you can and that's pretty much
all you can
do in a second we're going to get to the
economic fallout which continues to just
be
horrendous meanwhile republicans and
democrats arguing over
how to shore up the economy while
americans are still in many places
banned from being able to work and as
covetous 19 continues to tear through
various communities in terms of case
diagnosis we'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that right now you're
thinking
maybe i need some life insurance correct
you do need life insurance if you're a
responsible person you need life
insurance make sure that your family
is taken care of with everything going
on right now a lot of people are asking
if it's even possible to buy life
insurance the answer is yes it is still
easy to shop
for life insurance if you have loved
ones depending on your income you
probably should right now
you could save 1500 bucks or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies when you're shopping
for a policy that could last for a
decade or more
the savings really start to add up what
is policy genius well it's an insurance
marketplace it's built and backed
by a team of industry experts here's how
it works step one you go to
policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need you compare quotes
from top insurers and find your best
price step two
apply for your lowest price step three
the policy genius team handles all the
paperwork and the red tape
policy genius works for you not the
insurance company so if you had any
speed bumps they will take care of
everything
with you there's a reason they have a
five-star rating across 1600 reviews
on trustpilot and google you shop
competitively get a better price make
sure you're saving money and get the
life insurance you need
head over to policygenius.com right now
to get started you could save 1500 bucks
or more per year by comparing quotes on
their marketplace policy genius when
it's when it comes to insurance
it's nice and vital to get it right go
check them out policygenius.com
okay so the economy continues to plummet
uh a bad headline from cnbc they say the
second quarter gdp plunged by a worst
ever 32.9 percent
amid a virus-induced shutdown that's not
correct the actual
economy plunged by about 9.5 percent in
the second quarter the annualized number
meaning if you extended it
over the course of the year it would
look like 32.9 but that's not correct i
mean you don't annualize
quarterly gdp numbers that doesn't make
a lot of sense
uh apparently it was the worst drop ever
the closest previously coming in mid
1921 mark zandi the chief economist at
moody said the report just highlights
how deep and dark the hole is
the economy cratered into in q2 he said
it's a very deep and dark hole
we're coming out of it it's going to
take a long time to get out and it's
going to take longer if we can't get
past
kovid 19. now we still don't know
whether
the tailing off that we've started to
see in texas and florida or the tailing
off that we saw in new york
is sort of a permanent tailing off or
whether as people go back to work and as
people get out there again
the thing's gonna uptick again as we hit
the flu season one of the assumptions of
a big second wave during flu season
was that there would be a tailing off
during the summer thanks to climate that
really didn't happen because it was so
hot outside everybody went inside and
then air conditioning gave
everybody the corona virus so the
assumption was it'll sort of tail off
during the summer and then it'll crop up
again
in the fall that that was true 100 years
ago right it was true during the 1918
pandemic because there was no air
conditioning where it was hot
people just didn't get it very much
because they weren't in small areas with
recirculated air
that obviously has not been happening in
fact there's been a reverse correlation
in the united states between places
where it is really hot and a decrease in
cases there's actually been an increase
in cases in places
where it's super hot because everybody's
going inside and getting covered so we
still don't know what that means in
terms of a second wave have we already
seen the second wave
we don't know at this point the one
thing that we do know is that more and
more americans are being added to the
unemployment rules apparently 1.4
million americans
joined the unemployment rolls again this
week which is really
scary stuff and many states still have
some form of lockdown
in place obviously los angeles pretty
much all the businesses
are still closed and there's heavy
restrictions on what you can
and cannot do in the city of los angeles
for example
well this means that there's been a lot
of debate inside congress about what to
do
in terms of continuing to prop up the
economy and make sure that people who
have basically been barred from work by
the government
are not the ones who take it directly on
the chin
republicans have been looking at some
sort of measured response
and democrats have been looking at just
blowing it out and spending on a variety
of idiocies that make no sense at all
now
even the republicans were looking at
spending on kind of random garbage there
was talk that president trump wanted
additional funding for federal buildings
in the in the
quote-unquote stimulus package again
this is not a stimulus package a
stimulus package
is when the economy is slow and you just
inject money in order to make the
economy go it is not when the government
has actually created mandates so that
you cannot work okay that is a different
thing
if the government came and paved over my
house as i've said a million times
if they pave over my house they have to
compensate me this seems to me
effectually attacking when you have the
government saying to people that you
cannot work
telling them they cannot go to work when
you have the government telling people
that if they do go to work they have to
obey
certain restrictions that make it nearly
impossible for their business to do
business
well that is a taking and just
compensation is required under the
constitution of the united states under
the under the takings clause of the
fifth amendment to the constitution of
the united states so
it seems to me that this looks more like
an eminent domain situation than like a
stimulus package that said
the way to make clear that that is the
case is to actually fill in the gap not
to just blow out the spending
so there's apparently a big gap between
republicans and democrats on exactly
how to fill in that gap nancy pelosi
says everybody's still really far apart
on this new quote unquote stimulus
package she says it's like trying to
breed a flamingo and a giraffe which is
a hell of a take by nancy pelosi
again we could come to some sort of
reasonable compromise here but she says
that uh this is not going to happen
apparently in a meeting she said it's
like a giraffe and a flamingo they're
both at a zoo a dumb person may think
they could mate for offspring
a smart person knows that's impossible
that's our bills they're unable to mate
white house chief of staff mark meadows
and treasury secretary steve mnuchin
were also in the meeting as with senate
minority leader chuck schumer
schumer said that the democratic bill
was a golden retriever and the gop
proposal was a chihuahua
he said a golden retriever can't mate
with a chihuahua you have a chihuahua we
have a beautiful lion
um i mean technically i don't know
enough about dogs
is that is that true um actually lions
can't mate with chihuahuas either
this is all weird why are we talking
about mating animals how about we just
talk about like
what we should do very strange stuff
happening in congress
one of the nice things about american
government is you always know you have
the best and the brightest
who are going to be handling your future
it's very it's very uplifting the the
gap is this
according to cnn senate republicans have
already unveiled a one trillion dollar
stimulus proposal this week
that would include a six hundred dollar
federal boost to unemployment checks
that expires july 31st
democrats are unifying behind a far
bigger and different proposal
republicans need some democratic support
so what exactly is this
are the payments so the senate
republicans want a second round of
direct stimulus payments they're worth
up to twelve hundred dollars for
individuals and twenty four hundred
dollars for families
it would send an individual an
additional 500 bucks per dependent
regardless of age
the first round excluded dependents were
older than 17. the size of the payments
would scale down starting with
individuals who earn more than 75 grand
a year and married couples earn more
than 150
000 and phase out all together for high
income individuals again that actually
doesn't make tons of sense
for the very reason that people have
basically
all incomes in the united states
especially if you're measuring based on
last year's income before the pandemic
everybody's getting hurt and everybody
has cost but put that aside that's a lot
of money
and they're talking about payments worth
up to 200 for individuals and 2 400
for family five hundred dollars per
dependent house democrats
want twelve hundred dollars per family
member maxing out at six thousand
dollars
per household six thousand dollars per
household which is an enormous amount of
money
and money that we do not have right and
would incentivize people not to go back
to work obviously one of the big
problems with the last stimulus package
is that if you are paying people 600 per
week in unemployment benefits and
supplementary
unemployment benefits then very often
people are being paid more to stay at
home
than they are to go to work which
you really don't want right i mean when
when the economic recovery does happen
when people go back to work you don't
want to be paying them to stay at home
on unemployment benefits the proposal
from the republicans would extend the
federal boost unemployment benefits but
at a reduced amount
it would call for cutting the weekly
payments to 200 bucks from 600 bucks
until states implement a system that
replaces roughly 70
of laid off workers wages basically
they're saying states have not been
footing the bill the fed's been putting
the bill states need to pick up the
slack
democrats want to extend the 600
enhanced unemployment benefit
through all the way through january all
the way through january just in time for
joe biden's inauguration is what
democrats are thinking
those receiving regular state benefits
at that time could continue receiving
the 600
boost as late as the end of march so
just forever
for all time okay so there's some pretty
significant gaps here the house
democrats include no additional money
for the paycheck protection program
so they just want to let businesses
basically go under and people can be
directly supported by the government
this is the house democrats way of
achieving universal basic income
is what this really looks like more than
anything also house democrats want to
provide 100 billion dollars in education
funds
it specifies that 69 59 billion would go
to k-12 schools 30
would go to higher education again i'm
confused
as to why we are blowing out the
education spending when schools
literally are not in session and as
we'll see teachers are saying they don't
even want to teach remote
the bill for the democrats also includes
a 500 500 billion
bailouts of states and 375 billion
bailouts local governments
which is pretty wild so they're just
filling in bad governance from a variety
of states so no wonder there's this big
gap
the answer is you can have arguments
over how much people should be receiving
on a personal level or on an
unemployment level
when you start with all the goodies the
paying off states and all of that you've
gotten into territory that has nothing
to do
with filling in gaps created by kovid in
the first place
in just a second we're going to get to
some cultural issues that have been
cropping up as of recently we'll get to
that in momentarily first
let's talk about something nice okay
like something nice hey let's talk about
something nice you can do for your
family
here is what it is you can have a
beautiful portrait painted of your
family by a professional artist and you
can do so without spending
an arm and a leg if you want a truly
meaningful gift you want to give
somebody a truly meaningful gift
go try paintyourlife.com you can choose
from a team of world-class artists and
work with them until every detail is
perfect
their user-friendly platform lets you
order a custom made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes you
can send any picture yourself your kids
family
a special place cherished pet or you can
combine photos in one painting it makes
a perfect birthday anniversary or
wedding gift
we have a giant paint your life portrait
hanging above our mantle pieces of
me and my wife and two of our children
we need to order a new one now because
we have baby
number three at paintyourlife.com there
is no risk if you don't love
the final painting your money is
refunded guaranteed right now it's a
limited time offer get 20 off your
painting
that's right 24 off and free shipping to
get the special offer text the word ben
to 64 000 that is ben 264 thousand text
the word ben
64 000 paint your life celebrate the
moments that matter most text bends 64
000 to get 20
off and free shipping and is a fantastic
fantastic gift go check it out right now
text ben 264 000 and join up with paint
your life okay so meanwhile teachers are
now saying that they don't even want to
return to online instruction
demonstrating once and for all the
teachers unions have little to do with
helping students and a lot to do
with helping teachers the new york times
reports teachers in many districts
are fighting for longer school closures
stronger safety requirements and limits
on what they are required to do in
virtual classrooms while flooding social
media and state capitals with their
concerns
and threatening to walk off their jobs
if key demands are not met clearly the
needs of the children are first and
foremost
in the minds of teachers who don't even
want to do online education
it is one thing to say you don't want to
go into school because you're 70 years
old and you don't want to get infected
and die
there's another thing to say you don't
want to be on video you don't want to do
a zoom call
on tuesday the nation's second largest
teachers union raised the stakes
dramatically
by authorizing local and state chapters
to strike if their districts do not take
sufficient precautions like
requiring masks and updating ventilation
systems before reopening classrooms
already teachers unions have sued
florida's governor over that state's
effort to require schools to offer
in-person instruction
even as unions exert their influence
they face enormous public and political
pressure because of widespread
acknowledgement
that you got to have kids back at school
apparently many of these teachers are
now upset that they even have to work at
all
so now they're saying that the teachers
went above and beyond work hours laid
out in emergency labor agreements
their members provided technical support
to families and answered emails and text
messages
from students and parents wow you know
that's rough considering you weren't in
school teaching
now representatives must balance the
concerns of an often feisty membership
against the urgent needs of vulnerable
children
well actually the representatives aren't
doing any of that kind of stuff at all
they're just caving to teachers
who aren't actually teaching that's
that is pretty incredible la the
nation's second largest school district
has already made the decision to start
the year online because of infections
now the union and administrators
are engaged in long negotiating sessions
via zoom with one of the sickest points
of contention being how many hours per
day
teachers should be required to teach via
live video
sicily meyer cruz president of the
united teachers los angeles union said
she understood the benefits
she watched her own son engage with
teachers online she argued that a full
school day over video would not be
feasible for either students or teachers
so you're not going to see people
engaged kids will turn off to that
instead they think that remote mental
health counseling should be available to
students so
basically they just don't want they want
to be paid to do nothing which is really
exciting stuff
well done all the way around so in other
chaotic news of the day
president trump decided that it would be
a good idea today to tweet out and then
pin to the top of his twitter page
a suggestion that election day should be
delayed so the president tweeted out
today quote with universal mail-in
voting not absentee voting which is good
2020 will be the most inaccurate and
fraudulent election in history
it will be a great embarrassment to the
united states delay the election until
people can properly securely and safely
vote
three question marks okay so
mail and voting is a bad idea it is a
bad idea it is rife with the possibility
of fraud no less than jimmy carter has
said something similar
in years past however the president of
the united states does not actually have
the power to delay the united states
election that requires an act of
congress
it's not going to happen mail inv two
things can be true mailing voting
can be a bad idea generally because it's
gonna take weeks to hash out because
there's the possibility of fraud
for all the reasons that we've talked
about before also
the president floating that he wants to
delay the election is like the worst
idea ever
it's a terrible political idea and now
we'll get a full 48-hour news cycle
on why dem why republicans won't
denounce the president for saying this
sort of stuff now the
the true answer is that the president
can say whatever he wants
again it takes an act of congress to
delay the election nobody has any intent
to delay this election it's not going to
happen
so you'll see that mentioned very low in
a lot of the news reports
but is that the kind of solidity that
people are seeking in a time of
great pandemonium are people feeling
solid
again the great benefit to joe biden in
this particular election is that all joe
biden has to do
is be barely alive that really is his
key
see if he's too alive then he makes a
lot of gaffes but if he's dead then he's
dead so he has to be just kind of like
barely alive
like barely alive is where he wants to
be because he can just point to trump
being extraordinarily volatile
and then when trump says he's senile all
biden has to do is just say
okay i may be senile but you're
incredibly volatile and you're not
senile so what happens when you get
senile
so trump trump's twitter is like the
worst thing that he can do right now it
is a very very stupid move
it's gonna be a two days news cycle but
it's really a giant nothing burger
meanwhile
remember that time the nba was super
woke and the nba is going to lecture us
all on social justice
incredible story from espn today an espn
investigation has found that coaches at
nba's china
academies are complaining of player
abuse and lack of schooling
according to espn long before an october
tweet in support of hong kong protesters
spotlighted the nba's complicated
relationship with china
the league faced complaints from its own
employees over human rights concerns
inside an nba youth development program
in that country
an espn investigation is found american
coaches at three nba training academies
in china told league officials their
chinese partners were physically abusing
young players and failing to provide
schooling even though commissioner adam
silver had said education would be
central to the program
according to multiple sources with
direct knowledge of the complaints
the nba ran into myriad problems by
opening one of the academies
in xianjiang the police state in western
china where more than a million uyghur
muslims
are now held in barbed wire camps
american coaches were frequently
harassed and surveilled in jeonjang the
sources said
one american coach was detained three
times without cause he and others
were unable to obtain housing because of
their status as foreigners
a former league employee compared the
atmosphere where he worked in shenzhen
to world war ii germany
in an interview with espn about its
findings nba deputy commissioner and
chief operating officer mark tatum who
oversees international
operations said the nba is reevaluating
and considering other opportunities for
the academy program
which operates out of sports facilities
run by the chinese government
last week the league acknowledged they
closed the xinjiang academy but they
refused to ignite
they refused to say whether human rights
were a factor we were somewhat humbled
said tatum
one of the lessons we've learned here is
we do need to have more direct oversight
and the ability to make staffing changes
when appropriate the program launched in
2016 was part of the nba strategy to
develop local players in a basketball
obsessed market that has made nba china
a 5 billion
enterprise most of the former employees
spoke on the condition
of anonymity one american coach who
worked for the nba in china described
the project as a sweat camp
for athletes at least two coaches quit
in response to what they believed was
mistreatment
of young players one requested and
received a transfer after watching
chinese coaches strike teenage players
three sources told espn another american
coach left before the end of his
contract because
he found the lack of education
unconscionable he said i couldn't
continue to show up every day
looking at these kids knowing they would
end up being taxi drivers
not long after the academy's opened
multiple coaches complained about the
physical abuse and lack of schooling to
greg stoltz the league's vp for
international operations it was unclear
whether the information was passed on to
the nba
in new york the nba would not make salt
available for comment
two of the former nba employees
separately told espn coaches that the
academy is regularly speculated
about whether silver had been informed
about the problems i said if silver
shows up we're all fired immediately
tatum said the nba did receive a handful
of complaints that chinese coaches
were mistreating players but they did
nothing about it apparently
they immediately informed local
authorities that the league had zero
tolerance for that behavior
but they didn't report the incidents to
the league at the time
or to or to tate them or to silver sure
sure or alternatively everybody decided
to look the other way because they're
making a bundle
in china the nba brought in elite
coaches and athletic trainers with
experience in the g league and division
one basketball to work at the academies
one former coach described watching a
chinese coach fire a ball into a young
player's face at point blank range and
then kick him in the gut
the kid was apparently 13 or 14 years
old
so good times with the with the nba in
china
i definitely want to hear about human
rights violations in the united states
from the nba i think i think that's what
that's what we definitely have to hear
about
these people are not hypocrites in any
way in just a second we're going to get
to a big tech hearing that happened on
the hill
yesterday there were some moments that
were not so great as always for congress
we'll get to that momentarily first gang
if you haven't heard by now about my new
book how to destroy america in three
easy steps it is officially on sale in
fact
it is the number two bestselling book on
amazon.com
for the week it was number three on the
new york times bestseller listed this
week
the book covers the disintegrationist
philosophy that is now prevalent in the
united states
the philosophy that says to make any
progress we have to tear down every
american system all the systems are
racist and sexist and bigoted
and homophobic you can see that
particular vision of the united states
playing out in real time before
our eyes as the cities burn how to
destroy america in three easy steps
details how this garbage world view has
gained cultural traction
offers suggestions on where we go from
here you can get your copy right now at
amazon or barnesandnoble.com if you like
the book
please hop in leave a five star review
keep it keeps it higher on the charts so
more people will see it
and enjoy it you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
now speaking of china now the fact is
not just the nba that is enthralled to
china so many of our big ten companies
are enthralled
to china enthrall to china as well it's
pretty incredible so yesterday
there was this big hearing at the at the
house judiciary committee
and it was participated in by the heads
of google and facebook
and twitter and apple and there was this
amazing exchange
in which various ceos were asked about
chinese intellectual property theft
and only one of these ceos was actually
honest so you had tim cook of apple
who basically denied that there was any
intellectual property theft
uh you have senator pichai of google who
said we
no idea never heard of it you have jeff
bezos saying that he's heard about it
and then you have zuckerberg who's like
yeah of course that's true
because facebook it is important to
recognize here
not all big tech companies are the same
facebook has been significantly more
pro free speech than any of the other
outlets
it is it is not particularly close
twitter is not the same thing as as
facebook
this is something that as we'll see
congress people don't know because they
don't understand how the interwebs work
it is also true that facebook has taken
a pretty antagonistic view
toward chinese regulations in a way that
apple has not that google has not that
amazon has not
and that is worthy of note you can see
the contrast in this particular exchange
do you believe that the chinese
government steals technology
from u.s companies i don't know of
specific cases where we
have been stolen from by the government
i have no firsthand knowledge of uh any
information stolen from google
congressman i think it's well documented
that the chinese government steals
technology from american companies
i haven't seen it personally but i've
heard many reports of it okay so
amazing how only zuckerberg is really
willing to come out and just say yeah
absolutely the chinese are stealing
corporations are willing to make money
virtually anywhere that is just an
aspect of profit seeking
that is why the government really needs
to be focusing on china not on big tech
so much
big tech you know there are some
problems inside big tech but the
question is whether you really want your
congress people in charge of big tech
is the question is to who should be in
charge when it comes to china that's a
very different thing
now listen the nba so long as the
government is not shutting like it's one
thing for the nba to be overtly
participating in human rights abuses
but for the nba to participate in trade
with china is not the end of the world i
mean
again that's perfectly legal it's why
the government of the united states
should really be focused in
on shutting down a lot of the avenues of
economic growth for china which is
indeed a geopolitical threat to the
united states and to its neighbors
mostly
instead we are focused in on attacking
our domestic corporations
some of them are the biggest hirers in
the united states and let's just be
frank about this like their their
problems with a lot of these
corporations there are
i mean google is obviously biased
against conservatives
the but the idea that you're going to
put congress in charge of
all the big tech companies and that
congress can do this better seems to me
bizarre
example yesterday a representative named
sensenbrenner
asked mark zuckerberg of facebook about
suspending donald trump jr there's only
one problem
sensing brenner was asking about twitter
that's completely different company was
reported
that donald trump jr got taken down for
a period of time
why did that happen
congressman well first to be clear i
think what you might be referring to
happened on
on twitter so it's hard for me to speak
to that but i can talk to our policies
about this
um we do prohibit content that will lead
to imminent risk of harm
and stating that there is a proven cure
for kovid when there is in fact none
um might encourage someone to go take
something that could have some adverse
effects so we do take that down
okay so i i do love that that he is
attacking zuckerberg for something that
another company did the truth is the
worst of these companies is twitter
twitter really is overtly censorious of
views they do not like in a way that
many of these other companies are not
it's also true that again google
has been acting with a certain amount of
political alacrity
to crack down on conservatives every
mistake the problem is they never let
anybody inside their data so it's very
difficult to tell
exactly which companies are are
discriminating against conservatives and
which ones
are not again i'll say that i don't
think that facebook is discriminating
against conservatives because it would
be hard for me to claim otherwise
considering that daily wire does very
well on facebook right i mean just on an
anecdotal level
it's hard for me as the head of a
company that that gets good traffic on
facebook to say facebook is cracking
down on us
i can say that when there have been sort
of weird instances
of google glitches they always seem to
target conservatives over at google so
distinguishing between the companies
seems to be something worthwhile
according to the new york post just a
couple of days ago google said it fixed
a bug that led to several conservative
websites disappearing from its search
results on tuesday but a former engineer
for the tech giant said the glitch may
have inadvertently exposed an internal
list
that targeted certain news outlets mike
wacker said it appears to have revealed
the existence of another blacklist that
disproportionately targets conservatives
he said the glitch is that sites on this
blacklist disappeared from google search
results but the existence of the list is
very much by design
and that raises a major question why
exactly does that list exist in the
first place
for several hours tuesday morning and
early afternoon users couldn't access a
number of websites on google search
including breitbart drudge report
bongino report
and the national pulse major newspapers
like the new york times and washington
post were not affected
we saw this by the way uh just maybe a
year ago when google decided they were
going to put
fact checker evaluations of only
conservative sites on the side of the
google page
so yeah google google's been a problem
for this representative jim jordan went
after google yesterday in this big tech
hearing
there's an email in 2016 that was
widely circulated amongst the executives
at your company
that got public where ms ileana morillo
head of your multicultural marketing
talks about the silent donation google
made to the clinton campaign
and you applauded her work she points
that out in the email i'm just curious
if you did it in 16 i want to make you
know in spite of the fact you did in 16
president trump won i just want to make
sure you're not going to do it again in
2020.
okay so it is true that google has its
biases now the question is is google a
monopoly so there are two sort of views
of monopoly
in law and american law one is the
consumer-based view
which is that so long as consumers are
not being job there is no monopoly
right monopoly is really based on
whether the consumer is being
overcharged or being exploited in some
way that they don't know about
through monopoly practices the other is
whether a company is just very very
large
i tend to toward the first vision
because there can be such a thing as a
natural monopoly
where when you break up the monopoly the
consumer is actually harmed and that
actually happened with windows and
microsoft was broken up in the late 90s
the idea being microsoft was too large
and then apple
ate microsoft's lunch so it turned out
that it wasn't even a monopoly in the
first place
and the answer to to google you know
having its own bias
is presumably for somebody to invest an
awful lot of money in alta vista or in
an alternative search engine google
didn't become a monopoly
simply by by dint of them being biased
they become monopoly by dental being
better at their job i mean
they spend an awful lot of money on
market research they're an enormous
company
and the notion that congress is going to
be able to successfully
control big tech i think is is a mistake
considering that most of the people in
congress
literally don't know what an internet is
so worth worthwhile
noting that worthwhile just keeping that
in mind
okay meanwhile there's a more
controversy brewing over the trump
administration president trump decided
to
tweet out again uh about the
about initiative that is that is called
the
affh the affh is
essentially a rule created by the obama
administration that gives federal power
over local zoning it's it's a it's a bad
policy it's
it's been a bad policy for quite a while
president trump tweeted out about it
with uh i would say uh probably the
worst available take
so the the affh again is a policy that
is designed to give the federal
government
a lever to re-engineer nearly every
american neighborhood is according to
stanley kurtz of the ethics
and public policy center imposing a
preferred racial and ethnic composition
densifying housing transportation and
business development in suburb and city
alike
weakening or casting aside the authority
of local governments over core
responsibilities
from zoning to transportation to
education
if the affh's reach is so widespread
because so many communities have become
far too dependent
on housing and urban development
programs like community development
block grants if a city
city or town wants federal housing
funding it would have to comply with
affh
the mandate's egregiousness was
magnified because they were using what
they call disparate impact
which means that if in fact the the
program
is administered neutrally and the impact
is disparate like
it impacts people differently then that
means that the program is somehow racist
so that gave the government enormous
power to basically deny housing and
urban development funding to localities
based on lack of preferred racial
contribution so let's say that the the
country at large is 13
black and a town received housing and
urban development funding
and then they use the housing and urban
development funding and the town's
composition
demographically went from 13 black to 9
black
then this would cause the federal
government to step in and rezone
the entire the entire town which takes
local control out of the hands of the
locals obviously
it's a bad policy it's been a bad policy
for a long time the heritage foundation
points out that the affh rightly came to
the sites of ben carson's hud soon after
change in administrations
in 2018 carson's housing and urban
development announced
the withdrawal of the 2015 mandates of
so-called local government assessment
tools in which communities had to report
non-housing-related information
this would then be used by the hud to
judge the efforts to diversify the
community
if federal bureaucrats believed the
community was not sufficiently quote
unquote diversified
the local jurisdiction would not get
federal funds intended to provide
affordable housing
so this basically required local
officials to answer questions on topics
like
significant disparities in access to
opportunities disproportionate housing
needs
local officials had to analyze and
report data on issues like access to
public transportation quality schools
and jobs
environmental health hazards in essence
it was the federal government stepping
in
and trying to control in top-down
fashion exactly how
towns were constituted even if those
towns were not creating policy to
bar people on the basis of raise i mean
a lot of this actually
is barred by federal law right federal
law bars the hud from conditioning
federal housing assistance on the type
of conditions
outlined in the new rule so it was a bad
rule the trump administration was right
to cut against it but trump tweeted out
i'm happy to inform all of the people
living their suburban lifestyle dream
you will no longer be bothered or
financially hurt by having low income
housing built in your neighborhood
your housing prices will go up based on
the market and crime will go down i have
rescinded the obama biden
a ffh rule enjoy okay so simply
saying um that you want to bar low
income people
from the suburbs that's not what this is
really
about okay that's that's not what this
is about it's about local control
and people moving out to the suburbs
wanting to be able to determine
what the nature of their community is on
a non-race-based
non-race-based basis right obviously
you're still barred by federal law and
state law from discriminating on the
basis
of race but it is true that one of the
reasons people move out to the suburbs
is because they want better public
schools for example and that means that
they're moving out to the suburbs
because
presumably people who can live in the
suburbs can afford to live in the
suburbs
and so it is not unreasonable to say i
don't necessarily
want to live directly next to a homeless
shelter right zoning regulations exist
in every city and town across the
country
because people want to be able to
control exactly the kind of
neighborhoods
they live in and there are certain
factors that shouldn't be taken into
account obviously racial segregation
would be one
but but the notion that the federal
government can on the basis of disparate
impact come in and control
how zoning is done in every community in
the united states is really bad trump
articulates that
in a way that is not particularly good
now in in good news for the trump
administration
to his credit they are doing something
good president trump is now extending
operation
legend to cleveland detroit and
milwaukee so this is giving more federal
resources to local law enforcement to
police high crime areas according to the
daily wire on wednesday the doj
announced it was extending operation
legend
which is an initiative in which the
federal law enforcement agencies work in
conjunction
with state and local law enforcement to
fight violent crime they're extending
that to albuquerque
from from albuquerque kansas city
missouri chicago to cleveland detroit
and milwaukee that is a good thing
if you'd like to see the crime go down
that'd be a that would be a positive
development the doj stated that
cleveland is currently experiencing a
significant increase in violent crime
homicides are currently up more than 13
shootings are up 35 over 2019 homicides
are up in detroit nearly 31
shootings resulting in wounds are up
over 53 percent in milwaukee
homicides are up 85 percent this year
non-fatal shootings are up 64
now this is not the same as deploying
federal agents in
in unmarked cars with
with the military fatigues that's that's
a completely different
federal initiative right that's
protecting federal property this is
sending more
federal forces as an adjunct to programs
that are anti-gang
or or anti-gun prevalent in major
american cities these the authority for
this already exists
on the books 25 federal investigators
from the fbi dea and atf are being sent
to cleveland supported by a million
bucks from the bureau of justice
assistance 42 federal agents are going
to be sent to detroit
and 25 more investigators are going to
be sent to milwaukee
this is a good thing it's a good thing
for all the talk about trump not caring
about people
of color this is specifically designed
to crack down on crime that
disproportionately affects people of
color
so the fact that trump is doing that
that is in fact a good thing of course
that's not going to be covered and if it
is covered he's going to be called the
fascist for now using federal resources
to help tamp down on crime
instead everybody is going to focus in
on president trump saying a dumb thing
about delaying the election
alrighty one quick note so i feel like
it's a good time to do this
so people wonder you know if it feels
like the show is slightly off today
that's because
today is a fast day means no eating it
means no drinking today is
tisha b'av yes tisha b'av it's the ninth
of av which is the saturday in the
jewish
calendar and just a quick note about
tisha b'av so for for those who care
about
cultural diversity tisha b'av is the
commemoration of the destruction of not
one but two temples
not a great day in jewish history and as
i say there's sort of a superstitious
belief in the jewish community that and
based on the evidence of all the bad
things that have happened on disability
this is a bad day just generally so not
a big shock the news
sucks today in any case tisha b'av
commemorates the destruction of the
first temple in jerusalem and 586
bce and the second temple in 70 ce
respectively people fast on the state
and they fast in commemoration
it's worthwhile noting that the
the thing that is being commemorated is
the destruction of the temple on top of
the temple mound so as i've said many
times on the show before
many in the media just get it wrong when
it comes to jerusalem they say things
like the western wall is the holiest
site in judaism
this is a lie the temple mount is the
holiest site in judaism it was usurped
and and then built over by muslims
frankly i mean that is the that is the
story here
is that judaism the this is
unfortunately
a habit of medieval islam is to take
religious sites
that belong to other religions and then
pave over them and then build a mosque
and it's actually not just medieval
islam
it's happening right now in turkey where
a church
was turned into a mosque turned into a
museum and turned back into a mosque now
in any case the temple mount was was
made into a
religious site for more than one
religion but it was originally a jewish
site obviously which is why you have
this giant flat area in the middle
of jerusalem there's a very famous
talmudic story
in which rabbi akiva maybe the most
famous rabbi in the talmud
is sitting shortly after the destruction
of the temple in 70 ce sitting with
other rabbis and they're all crying and
he starts laughing and they ask why
and he says well do you see the fox that
is running through the temple mount and
they say yes he says well there's the
prophecy that says that
the temple will be destroyed and a fox
will run through
through its ruins and now we've seen
that and the good news is that
eventually the temple will be rebuilt
because that's the other half
of the prophecy so the the going jewish
notion is that one day the
tisha b'av will be a day of rejoicing as
opposed to a day of
tragedy uh one of the other reasons it's
worth while noting this is because
whenever people try to eviscerate the
history of israel by suggesting that
basically it was just a repository of
european jews recognize that the dream
of jerusalem has been on the table for
some 4 000 years in judaism
and the bizarre notion put forth by
idiots like seth rogen
on widespread podcast that there's no
jewish connection to the land of israel
or that if there is jewish connection he
doesn't like religion so
obviously seth rogen knows best or seth
rogan suggested the jews would be
better off dispersed throughout the
world why would you put all the jews in
one place if you're worried about risk
to them well i think that the history of
the world has shown that whatever jews
are there tends to be a threat
and the history of israel has shown that
the fact that there is a jewish state
willing to defend
jewish rights in places that are not
israel has been quite good for jews
generally speaking
the the the revitalization of the state
of israel is a
glorious thing and uh as in orthodox jew
uh we pray every day for the restoration
of a temple
there is a way believe it or not there's
a way that that can be done without the
destruction it's kind of controversial
but there's some opinions that say
there's
there's a way that can be done without
the destruction of the dome of the rock
for example
but bottom line is that if you want to
know anything about jewish history study
tishb
because the story of the jewish people
and the destruction of those two temples
demonstrates
the ever-present commitment and
connection
between jews and the land of israel
it is it is not merely just a bunch of
white people who arrived on
quote-unquote arab land
that is complete revisionist nonsense
alrighty we'll be back here
later two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover and robert sterling
assistant director pablo wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan associate producer katie
swinerton
edited by adam syavets audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair
and makeup is by nika geneva the ben
shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20. you know the
matte wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses
are life family faith
those are fundamental and that's what
this show is about i hope you'll
give it a listen
you